foreign
sex-specific differences in myocardial
injury incidents after covid-19 mRNA
1273 booster vaccination now the
interesting thing about this study is
instead of looking at people who showed
up in a medical setting complaining of
issues that then turned out to be
myocarditis or pericarditis what they
did is they simply censused the blood of
people who took a booster for troponins
which are a marker of cellular damage in
the heart
so in other words this is a test in some
sense of what we've talked about
previously on the podcast which is if
you're seeing all of these cases of
myocarditis how many cases are you not
seeing because they didn't reach a point
where the person sought medical help for
them right they had some pain they
misunderstood what it was they never
showed up in a doctor's office which is
still potentially life reducing right
myocarditis is a serious condition and
uh it is profoundly associated with
shortened lifespan
so it is good to know how many of these
subclinical cases there are and in this
study as reported by do you want to read
what you got there yeah this is just
from the abstract among 777 participants
median age 37 69.5 women that's just
right that's a sample uh four right
sorry uh 40 participants had elevated
hsctnt concentration on day three and
mRNA 1273 vaccine Associated myocardial
injury was adjudicated in 22
participants and one of the interesting
things that come out of this is not just
the remarkably High rate of of heart
injury associated with the boosters uh
it was about 1 in 35 but that as I say
here in the abstract 20 cases occurred
in women 3.7 percent and two in men 0.8
percent and these are
um you know mild and only temporary so
they're they're referring to these as
transient which is why presumably they
haven't been caught previously but that
it's a it's a much higher higher rate in
women than in men which is of course the
opposite direction of the less transient
injury transient injury that we've been
hearing about more and you know of
course what is part of what is raised
here is uh what does it mean that it is
transient right the indicator is
transient is true but that doesn't mean
that there aren't lasting effects right
and in fact
as I have pointed out again and again
the heart is a very special tissue in
which damage is it produces a scar
rather than a proper repair even in
tissues where you have a proper repair
there's a limit in almost all tissues
there are a couple of exceptions but in
almost all tissues there is a limit to
how much repair you can do in a lifetime
so even if you have a repair in which a
loss of function is not detectable what
these things do is they Advance the
Aging of those tissues so that you can
you know you get a certain number of
those repairs in life
and if you keep breaking the same thing
you exhaust them early right or you know
in my case I lost teeth because an
orthodontist moved my teeth too rapidly
and he burned up my lifetime capacity
for repair in jaw tissue and so anyway
the jaw tissue has a higher capacity for
repair than your heart test vastly
vastly higher and it has a built-in
system for dealing with minor motions of
teeth because your skull shape changes
over a lifetime but put that aside the
heart is one of a small number of
tissues that has essentially no capacity
for proper repair that is to say cells
do not get replaced in kind what they
get replaced with is scar tissue that
allows the heart to continue to function
but you don't regain the capacity of the
fully functional heart that you damaged
so the expectation is these troponins
are a useful marker you ever wonder how
if you have something that seems to be a
heart attack and uh you recover within a
couple of days they can test you and see
whether you did have a heart attack it's
markers like this that they use so
anyway the fact that these markers show
up suggests damage to the heart the idea
that the markers are transient as you
point out doesn't mean that the damage
is transient and all of it is pretty
scary because myocarditis is
demonstrated to be a life shortening
condition
um so anyway one does have the sense
that the paper was written to emphasize
the transientness you know here's an
interesting finding but maybe it uh you
know I don't I I didn't actually get
that I've I've skimmed the paper and I
did not get the sense that they were
um trying to emphasize the transientness
but trying to be very careful about uh
saying the the as you say the markers
that we used were transient right but in
any case the idea that if you test
people who got
um this shot
without them having to show up reporting
a complaint and you find a 1 in 35 rate
and you know it's not a huge sample size
but nonetheless one in 35 is a huge
number of people to have a heart injury
from a vaccine that was given where
almost all of the people it was given to
would have recovered from covid on its
own didn't need a shot to protect them
and what's more the shot didn't protect
them the shot did not prevent
transmission or contraction and it even
now seems to make contraction of the
disease more likely if you get enough of
these things so the whole thing is is an
incredible debacle it raises questions
for me of course about what what this
research would look like in people after
getting their their first Rex the first
vaccine because this is of course in
people already vaccinated Hospital
workers already vaccinated going in for
their boosters so you know is is this a
higher rate than we would see after a
first or second vaccine my guess is yes
um that there there is cumulative damage
Associated uh that these that these
markers May persist for longer or come
on uh in more people the more the more
these shots people get but I don't I
haven't seen that research so I don't
know well it depends
sorry I should say I haven't seen that
research because I don't think it's been
done it depends radically on the
mechanism of action of the damage and
this is we're going to get a little
deeper into this in the next little
section but you know depending uh
Mark Gerardo I think is his last name
Advanced what I think is a high quality
Theory Mark or high quality hypothesis
Mark
um believes it is the reason for the
damage I believe it is a contributor but
his point was he calls it bolus Theory
and the idea is that a bolus dose that
gets into your bloodstream by virtue of
the needle not having been aspirated and
occasionally hitting a vein results in a
large amount of this mRNA coded in lipid
nanoparticle flooding tissues of the
body and when a big dose of it hits the
heart
you get the equivalent of an internal
burn right because those cells are taken
up they're then killed by the immune
system this is the thing I've been
arguing that this thing properly
transfects cells it wasn't supposed to
transfect those cells get destroyed by
the immune system and if that's in your
heart it's a disaster that does not
require it to be a bolus dose that can
be any dose any cell that gets
transfected in your heart will then be
attacked by your immune system but
um but in any case if it's the bolus
dose issue so that each time you get one
of these shots and the needle is not
aspirated you're running the risk of a
bolus dose then the basic point is
you're it's a lottery each time and so
you wouldn't necessarily expect a big
difference between the first shot the
second shot the third shot is just that
each time the chances that the needle
lands in a vein would predispose you to
an injury and the point is oh God that's
really scary if it's 1 in 35 each time
then three shots in you're 3 and 35. so
it's a distinction between
um cumulative versus everyone is an
independent uh crapshoot rather like the
risk from say some of the
um radioactive particles uh that have
that may be uh in fish from Fukushima
yeah exactly exactly
um so in any case the the large
background rate of a this is not a minor
issue and you would have damage even if
the thing worked correctly but the
damage would be in a tissue where you
could afford it if the thing worked
according to its design the point at
which it escapes your your deltoid and
is circulating in the body it's a
crapshoot in that regard too and the
fact is
again we're dealing with 1 in 35 which
is an unacceptably large rate but now
imagine that you know they're not
looking at markers for damage to your
kidneys
1 in 35. detectable heart damage or a
single the third dose of a particular
shot if that number is either
cumulative or in some other way
compounding then we need to understand
what that pattern is further
if we're not checking for markers to
damage to other tissues as you point out
in the Fukushima fish example you don't
find what you're not looking for
the so now we have to be very precise
here
a good vaccine let's say a
um a attenuated virus-based vaccine
will cause some damaged tissues because
the immune system will Target the cells
that have been infected by this
attenuated virus
however it will not be the bodywide
crapshoot that the MRNA vaccines are
because whatever virus was attenuated
had a particular ecology where it was
focused on invading cells that were
useful to it and not focused on any
salad encounters so there will be a
limit to the amount of damage and
that was simply absent from the design
of the MRNA shots there is no targeting
whatsoever the targeting was entirely
about where it was injected and the fact
that we knew that it escaped from the
deltoid means the body is all open to
being transfected with this stuff and so
therefore
what can we say
unlike a normal vaccine there will be
damage across many tissues that damage
could be widely distributed and in many
tissues that will be unimportant right
you'll not be able to measure a
difference doesn't mean no damage we
shouldn't think of it as no damage but
we should say undetectable in any
concentrated way
as as even
um
compelling traditional
vaccines would cause which is net
beneficial because
um well let's put it this way if you
take an attenuated virus vaccine it has
almost no reason to attack a cell in
your heart
because the heart is not a good place
from which to spread to other people so
the heart would be isolated from that
damage by virtue of The evolutionary
Ecology of the virus that was attenuated
because no such thing exists with the
MRNA platform what we have to say is
look this is going to transfect some
heart cells it's going to result in the
immune system attacking those heart
cells there are people for whom that's
just simply not a risk worth taking it's
lots of them
an mRNA
vaccine in quotes is inherently
indiscriminate because you've you've
abandoned The Selective pressure of the
original organism
virus
and of course with SARS Kobe 2 we have
that two times because you've already
abandoned the original selective
pressure of the original virus by
creating a Franken virus in a lab based
on an original virus so you've got some
selective environment that still the
public health authorities and the
researchers aren't being honest about
with regard to how this thing was
created in the first place and then
you've got a vaccine that is that is
only providing instructions to make the
spike protein and that will go anywhere
as opposed to an attenuated virus
vaccine which is still driven by its you
know unconscious all of this but it's
evolutionary its original evolutionary
pressure to get to tissues where it can
then spread to other in individuals
potential hosts yep so for two big
reasons we've got these uh these mRNA
so-called vaccines
that are more likely to do damage than a
traditional attenuated virus vaccine yes
and I would point out that the logic of
the attenuated virus vaccine is somewhat
sketchier with the adenovector dna-based
coveted vaccine but it's a lot closer
because they did borrow an existing
virus right it's not an attenuated virus
what
um the logic that says an attenuated
virus is limited by The ancestral
Ecology of the virus that was attenuated
this is you know the the dna-based
vaccine they borrowed a wholly different
virus right it's not SARS Kobe II so it
is effectively an attenuated virus but
because there's new technology here it
is less it hasn't been fully stripped of
its evolutionary background right and so
the evolutionary background will have it
targeted on whatever cells that
ancestral virus that they've borrowed no
I don't know what you know what the
evolutionary Ecology of that of the
adenovirus I don't know um
nature and it did something and and we
know in that something wasn't spreading
from host to host by targeting heart
cells right exactly the the point is a
virus has an interest in leaving you
intact in tissues where it is not
getting an advantage by replicating
because uh you spread it more if you're
is still up on your feet right it's not
like a
mosquito-borne uh pathogen where
knocking you flat on your back actually
serves the the pathogen the virus wants
you on your feet enough to spread it and
so that will apply to the Adeno virus
that the DNA vaccines are based on it
does not apply to the pseudovirus that
is effectively what the MRNA vaccines
are based on
Okay so
we've got some huge rate if we look only
at the heart we've got a huge rate of
subclinical injuries
from a particular inoculation of a shot
that people got many inoculations of and
we don't yet know the story of how those
inoculations compound so that is a
frightening and important picture as
John Campbell says if Regulators don't
take notice of this what the hell is
going on right how can they miss this
[Music]
foreign